when I was little I had a really bad
stress rash right here on Dance Moms
JoJo siwa reveals she developed bald
spots and says stress from Her Dance
Moms days played a part at the bottom of
the pyramid
check out this video JoJo posted to tick
tock it's a series of photos from her
time on Dance Moms accompanied by text
on screen that says when someone notices
my bald spot and wonders what it's from
[Music]
a confused fan left a comment asking
JoJo to clarify could the bald spot be
from her signature type ponytail instead
of commenting back JoJo made another
video to set the record straight no it's
actually not from the ponytails because
if it was for my ponytails considering
it went on this side it would be this
because this didn't really get pulled at
all in JoJo's original post she explains
just how she started losing her locks
quote stress rash on my head when I was
on Dance Moms led to no more hair there
when I was little I had a really bad
stress rash right here on Dance Moms and
I would pick at it all day long and I
damaged every single hair follicle of
that has ever been right there but
there's not just physical damage many of
JoJo's former Dance Mom stars have been
vocal they felt emotionally damaged by
the show and dance coach Abby Lee Miller
too they distanced themselves I don't
know how you don't give credit to
someone they all all of them
all the kids all the moms act as if
I had nothing to do with the show nor my
studio but not JoJo she's one of the
only dancers who has a good relationship
with Abby listen I will always remember
where I came from and everyone had a
different experience with Abby and a
different experience with Dance Moms
Abby actually taught me a lot you know
Abby has a lot of dance knowledge and
and I I carry a lot of what she taught
me with me cheers
and JoJo's respect for Abby shows the
singer dancer told E.T last month she
wants to pitch her old coach for the
judging panel on So You Think You Can
Dance I wanted to suggest that the
producers are so bad Abby Lee but then I
was like I don't think they'd think it
was a good I was like it was like kind
of a joke but also like it would work
out well like she is a dance brilliant
genius as for JoJo's fellow Dance Moms
castmates Nia Sue and Maddie Ziegler
seems they're keeping a healthy distance
that show like put me through a lot like
please and like being the only black
dancer on that show of course I endured
some things that like just probably like
people don't even know about I'm so
grateful for the show because it got me
to where I am today and uh it's helped
me you know with so many opportunities
and I'm so grateful for that
[Music]
thank you